quelle va être maintenant le sort des
100 papiers évacués ce matin de l'église
Saint-Bernard tout d'abord les gréistes
de la fin transférés vers les hôpitaux
militaires de clamar et Saint-Mandé ils
ont été placés sous le régime de la
garde à vue ceci afin de s'assurer
qu'ils ne quittent pas leurs
établissements cette garde à vue ne peut
excéder 48h au bout de 20h les gardés à
vu peuvent demander avoir un avocat
quant au 20 hommes et femmes parmi eux
68 enfants évacués vers le centre de
rétention de Vincen tous ont été placés
sous le régime de la rétention
administrative cette rétention résulte
d'un arrêté préfectoral pris
conjointement avec un arrêté de
reconduite à la frontière si un avion
est prêt à partir la mesure peut être
exécutoire dans les 24 heures passer ce
délai un juge judiciaire doit être saisi
ce dernier statut sur l'assignation à
résidence au total cette assignation ne
peut excéder 10 jours reste le
traitement politique de ce dossier le
ministre de l'Intérieur Michel Debray en
a fixé le cadre ce matin
pour la
première
catégorie celle des régularisables ils
recevront un titre de séjour et ceci dès
la semaine
prochaine pour les personnes de la 2e et
3e
catégorie et qui ne sont pas
régularisables
et pour lesquels il existe dès
maintenant des arrêtés de reconduite
exécutoire cette reconduite sera mise en
œuvre selon la CFDT un avion militaire
chargé de transporter les expulsés
aurait été réquisitionné le décollage
serait prévu demain matin au départ de
l'aérodrome militaire de
CR au chapitre des réactions très
nombreuses aujourd'hui condamnation à
gauche approbation à droite il fallait
clarifier les choses parce que on
prenait un peu tout de même avec un un
manque de dignité cette église pour un
Fort Chabrol qui était devenu l'absè
fixation de bien d'autres volontés de
récupération et de politisation il faut
maintenant apaiser les choses comme le
premier ministre l'a souligné hier avec
beaucoup de volonté d'apaisement et bien
il y aura une réponse qui sera apportée
à chacun des cas mais on ne peut pas
étudier un dossier administratif
ailleurs que derrière un bureau avec un
fonctionnaire et puis quelqu'un qui
vient défendre sa situation
véritablement l'intervention de ce matin
est plus qu'inopportune condamnable et
en tant que maire du 18e je veux vous
dire que les images qui ont pu être vu
soit sur le terrain soit à la télévision
sont assez assez dramatiques pour un
pays comme le nôtre n'occultons pas les
problèmes économiques et sociaux qui
touchent beaucoup de nos concitoyens
français ou immigrés et ça en plus je
pense que c'est vraiment comme le disait
François Hollande plus qu'un manque de
savoir-faire il ont pas l'art de
gouverner je sais pas s'ils finiront un
jour par apprendre sentiment de honte
profonde nous sommes ici même devant une
églises les églises sont des lieux de
refuge des lieux sacrés on ne force pas
des portes des églises avec des barres
de faire quand on peut négocier si on ne
peut pas négocier on est quelquefois
obligé de recourir à des violences mais
là tout était possible la négociation
était entamée il fallait la poursuivre
la violation de cette église est un
scandale
les partisans des sans papiers c'étent
prévisible se sont mobilisés toute la
journée avec en point d'org une
manifestation ce soir à la République
ils sont extrêmement nombreux à l'URE
présente on parle de plusieurs milliers
de personnes cette manifestation
rassemble syndicat parti politique de
gauche Parti socialiste et Parti
communiste notamment le cortège ira de
la République à la nation et nous
suivrons son évolution en direct dans
notre édition
régionale